[Applaudissements]
alors les scop star hier le critique
cinéma vous savez qui donne toujours son
avis géraldine 1 il est parfois bon il
est parfois mauvais et christophe
carrière aujourd'hui et sans chaussettes
donc à mon avis quand il est comme ça il
est plutôt de bonne humeur
alors mais j'aurais volontiers donné mon
avis géraldine à arrêt au bada on n'a
pas voulu montrer le film à venir
j'étais à mon âge on n'a pas oublié au
ventre quand ce n a pas voulu
oui on n'a pas de talent et pourquoi pas
sont déjà en vacances non mais je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce qu'il s'était
dans une salle de cinéma
et à chaque fois qu'il vient voir un
film le mec qui est derrière lui ne voit
rien à côté c'est bon on va le basé lui
et on lui paraît bon on veut plus le
voir
l'ex de ma vie ça sort jeudi pardon
demain mercredi local oui allez payer
pour voir la place non pas l'ensemble
payer la place balle va pas revenir pour
vous en parler à la pas que ça non donc
vous êtes une jeune violoniste
voilà vous jouez un peu du plomb londres
a dit pas du tout pas du tout comment
vous avez fait au psg j'ai pu j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un coach avait que
trois mois et j'ai appris à faire
semblant de faire du jeu mais bougez
massacrait mes voisins parce qu'il n'ya
pas de sourdine sur les violences j'ai
fait trois mois de doro d'horreur une
galère que pour le goûter a ouais
c'était que de la diplomatie et que du
geste que du c'était une ultra humiliant
mais dormi dans le fixe a fait ça fait
la blague on a l'impression qu'elle est
à mon avis c'est vrai on a été aidé par
la réalisatrice qu'elle est les jouets
fait du violon elle pas du tout elle
fait du cinéma non qu'elle a su que vous
connaissez tous la phrase qui fait du
cinéma et du violon et qui fait du
violon fait du cinéma
bien sûr on connaît bien sûr ça marche
dans les deux sens un bien sûr alors